the Joe Rogan experience you know what I
know you're big on aliens I just don't
believe it I mean we talked about this
last time don't believe it at all
I believe this other life-forms just
don't believe they've been here I don't
think they're coming here
no I there's no reason to come here we
are offering nothing what are you
talking about what are we offering job
well if you're that far people travel to
go study small mammals in the Congo do
you know that yes they spend giant
chunks of their life to go look at
butterflies we found a new frog in South
America and the National Geographic
Society will give them money we've gonna
document this frog people are curious
and anything that's going to be
intelligent and innovative anything
that's going to invent technology the
only reason why you invent technology is
because you are curious and if you are
curious you're not going to stop being
curious you're gonna continue to be
curious and if you have a [ __ ] whole
planet filled with predatory Apes that
have thermonuclear weapons and they want
to control various patches of land that
they've designated on maps with lines
and they put stupid [ __ ] fences up
and they nuke each other and they
[ __ ] fly planes and drop bombs out
and they have other planes that they
[ __ ] operate remotely with these
little joysticks and drop bombs on
people we killed terrorists and some of
the people that run the country are
terrorists and and then you have for the
stock market like what the [ __ ] are
these people doing the stock markets
what is that a bunch of numbers that are
bouncing around they're trying to
speculate what's gonna go this and it's
based on confidence oh my god these
people are crazy and then they have the
ability to send video through the air
and it reaches their phone on the other
side of the world instantaneously like
whoa this is really heavy stuff
these [ __ ] crazy monkeys down on
planet Earth are weird we should study
them of course they would study us there
we're sending rockets into space we're
invading other other planets in our
solar system to try to colonize if
they're coming here
yeah that's basic to them all that stuff
you just soldier bases who is it - so
you know to get here they have to have
technology we haven't even know they
don't know they have to have technology
that's slightly more advanced than us we
will be able to unquestionably travel to
other planets within a hundred years
or 200 years let's say three let's say
300 okay so it's comparing us to people
that live in 1720 right that's not that
long okay so it's like we went back in
time to visit people in the 1700s we'd
be fascinated and we'd be very
interested if we found a planet
somewhere 300 years from now that had
people on that planet that live like
people lived here in the 1700s we would
be blown away I just think it's the most
unique and interesting thing we've ever
found ever in life
I just don't know with everyone having a
cell phone can take footage why don't
they have like real why don't multiple
people have the same footage of the same
thing like it had they do there are some
sightings particularly the Phoenix
lights that happened in the 90s that
many many people captured you don't know
exactly what they are they don't know
what it but this a lot of people
captured these lights that are in the
sky now my take on the Phoenix lights
and a lot of these things is usually
that there's some sort of a military
aircraft we're working on but here's the
thing they don't have to visit all the
time if they only visited once or twice
these unique experiences that have
happened once or twice over the course
of human history or three times or ten
times or a hundred times what are the
odds that anyone's going to capture it
especially if they're smart about it
especially they're smart about how they
come especially if they have some sort
of cloaking apparatus or they have some
ability to understand whether or not
they're being viewed or observed and
know knowing how to hide or how to
camouflage the ships but of course they
would be interested I know that's the
least plausible scenario that they
wouldn't be interested in us the thing
that kind of the thing that was
interested in me when you interviewed
snow his he's been through everything
and he found no weapon it's noted he
found no evidence but he hasn't been
through everything first of all he's
only one man and he was only working
there for a short amount of time okay
it's all use what he had access so last
but it's not like he's working there for
hundreds of years and deeply diving into
the subject of UFOs and has access to
and not only that like what does he have
access to is access to the NSA files and
like everything's compartmentalized you
know that's one of the big problems with
the military said the NASA does not have
access to what the Navy has access to
which doesn't have access to what the
Army has access to like they don't
always cooperate and just so for him to
say that
didn't find anything about UFOs that
makes sense like he probably even looked
a little bit and didn't find thing about
UFOs that doesn't mean there's nothing
about UFOs it just means that he didn't
find anything okay okay there's a lot of
information out there when you think
about one person that's gonna scour all
the government records understand from
the 1950s to present about what they've
discovered and what they haven't so you
so area 51 what do you think that's in
there do you think there now you think
okay I think at one point time is what
well it is for sure one point time what
they use to work on secret military
projects or aircrafts and that's where
the Blackbird came out of that's where
the stealth bomber came out of there was
a lot of that stuff that a lot of people
mistook for UFOs I think the real
question lies in the very small
percentage of unexplained sightings so
if you look at UFO sightings you take
the pie of UFO sightings I would say
there's a not me they say what they're
talking about that's been solved is
somewhere in the neighborhood of ninety
five percent of those ninety-five
percent can be explained by swamp gas
ball lightning ball lightning is a
phenomena that comes when depending upon
tectonic pressure the earth can release
this lightning that the ground that
travels in a ball shaped pattern and
zigs through the sky and then vanishes
and disappears
they don't totally understand how it's
being created but they do know it
requires some pressure in the earth
something about tectonic plates and
possibly different atmospheric
conditions but it's a real observable
phenomena that's actually occurred on
planes before like it's flown down the
done the passageway of a jet at one
point in time yeah people multiple
people observe this ball lightning and
they thought they were being boarded by
a [ __ ] UFO or something
it's a weird Eva never seen it no it's
very weird phenomena see get a video on
we should probably wrap this up tuned
it's three hours and 30 minutes get that
yet get a video on ball lightning
because they have observed this in film
this it's really fascinating
that's that's responsible for a lot of
UFO sightings but you said there's that
five percent the factory
out of that five percent 4% they just
haven't figured out how to explain like
let me see this see like that is ball
lightning okay hovering in the sky and
sometimes they'll fly around sometimes
not only do they hover in place but they
move around so lightning crackles and
then this thing will hover in the sky
and then sometimes they actually come
out of the ground you know this is bad
comparison probably but it's almost like
an ash you know when you this is a bad
video see if there's some you know I
understand but the problem is there's
all this other people talking in it
there's different videos with ball
lightning that I've watched it's pretty
interesting [ __ ] man ball lightning is
weird because it's uh it's see like like
there it's okay it flies around and it
looks like a [ __ ] UFO see and then
disappears so okay that's a weird one
that's a weird one that kind of looks
like it would be an alien spacecraft and
then they get videos of it and you know
it looks like a ball flying through the
sky oh my god but it's just a very rare
atmospheric occurrence huh oh yeah yeah
but I think if I was an alien species
five hundred years more advanced than we
are I would be [ __ ] fascinated by
earth and that was that's all you need
five hundred years from now with the
exponential growth of technology like
we're experiencing on earth five hundred
years from now if we don't blow
ourselves up or if they're different
than us like maybe they evolved
different and they don't have the same
battle for resources so they didn't
develop the kind of territorial behavior
that us apes have if they develop
something more complex in a different
sort of cooperative evolutionary
mechanism they could be very different
than us but still way more advanced but
interested in us okay all right will you
ever see one in your lifetime take the
right dose
[Applause]